翻訳: 椿原 脩平
校正: Hiroko Kawano
スクリーンに映っているのは
2008年9月28日の日です
スケートボードによる
史上最長の旅を終えた瞬間です
この瞬間に先立って ヨーロッパの一部を
スケートボードだけで横断しました
そしてその後 ヨットで大西洋を渡って
アメリカを
スケートボードだけで横断しました
フロリダからカリフォルニアまでですね
そして最後に中国も
スケートボードだけで横断しました
合計で12,159kmを スケートボードで
１年半をかけて走行しました
そして2009年6月に
ギネス世界記録として承認されました
しかし このスケートボードによる
旅の直前には
2006年6月から自転車で
ユーラシア大陸の13,000kmを
１年かけて横断しました
なので スケートボードの旅と
自転車の旅を合わせると
２年半の旅となりました
すべて独りでの旅であって
海を渡る以外のときは 全て自力でした
そしてもちろん現地の人々からの助けは
たくさんあったのですけれども
原則として外部サポートは
一切ありませんでした
このような話を聞くと
ほとんどの人は
一体どうしてだと反応します
そのような反応は
自然で当たり前だと思います
じゃあ どうしてなのでしょうか？
自転車で世界一周とか このような
大きなアドベンチャーをする人たちの中で
「チャリティ―」とか
「環境保護のプロモーション」とか
そういった理由で
やっている人の話はよく聞きます
私も 身体障がい者のための
募金活動のプロモーションとして
一時的にアピールしましたけれども
それが主な目的ではありませんでした
よく考えたら 自分の旅は単なる
自己中心的なアドベンチャーでした
私が当初欲しがっていたのは
現代人の楽な暮らしを後にして
星空がきれいで静かな
砂漠の中で野宿をしたい
安全すぎる現代社会を捨てて
リスクを感じたい
恐ろしく荒れた山峠の道で
自分のメンタル的な強さに挑戦したい
そして これらをすべて
自力で経験したくて
弱いサラリーマンのような体を
スーパーマンのような体にしたかった訳です
少なくともこれがですね
出発する前に抱いていた
ファンタジーでした
夢って 多くの場合はそうですよね
単なるファンタジーで 至らなくて
実現しないことが多いです
しかし 私がこの旅に出発する前の１年間は
もうとにかくこの夢で夢中になっていました
「お金と時間があれば
大きなアドベンチャーをするのだ
夢を実現するのだ」
そう宣言する人は多いと思います
私が出発する前に
夢が単なるファンタジーでありながらも
もうとにかく実現させたかったのです
出発する前の１年間前に
2005年の終わり頃に
時間とお金 そのふたつの理由で
旅に出るか出ないか
すごく迷っていた時期はありました
しかしそのときによく考えたら
仕事をやめればいくらでも
時間は作れるのだと
お金はたくさんないのですけれど
毎晩野宿をしてもよければ
お金は何とか１年間はもつのだと
そういう風に気づきました
この夢を実現させるのであれば
今しかないのだと
実現させるか 後悔するか？
そのふたつの選択肢しかないのだと
強く感じました
なので早速
この夢を実現させるための
計画を立て始めました
その当時は旅とか自転車ツーリングとか
全くしたことがありませんでしたので
まずグーグルで
「自転車ツーリング」を検索して
自転車ツーリングのブログを
１年間かけて読み続けて情報を集めました
図書館に行って
世界地図を調べてコピーして
アパートの一面の壁を
ユーラシア大陸の地図にしました
画鋲と糸を使って
ユーラシア大陸を横断する
ラフなルートを立てました
毎朝目が覚めると
何よりも先に目に入ったのは
ユーラシア大陸 —
自分が立てた夢です
実際に出発の日が来たら
もう旅全体のほとんど半分は
もう終わっていたと思っています
そうなんです それほど
計画の段階が 重要で大変でした
振り返ってみても
その１年間の計画の段階は
旅の全体の大部分であったし
全体の50％の努力と苦労は
その計画の段階に占めていました
あと残っていたのは
その計画の実行だけでした
しかし 実際に旅立つとですね
当初抱いていたファンタジー
その 夢ですね —
その欠点に見事に直面しました
出発する前には 自分がヒーローで
なんでも —
自分の力で前向きで
問題を乗り超えるのだと
そういうようなファンタジーが
頭の中にありました
しかし 実際に旅立つと
自分の強さではなくて
自分の弱さを見事に知りました
特に自分のメンタル的な弱さを
見事に知りました
もちろん絶好調で
期待もしていなかった嬉しさを
感じることもありました
下り道で 追い風の強い日は
もうなんともいえない嬉しさで
いっぱいでした
何の抵抗なしで
すいすい走ることができました
しかし そのような日は
ほんのわずかでした
実はほとんどの日は
苦しい肉体労働のようでした
このような毎日の苦労が続くと
どんどん鬱になっていきました
この時期は
かなりメンタル的な勝負でした
頭の中で 様々な否定的な
思考パターンに陥っていきました
例えば自分の一日の走行距離を
他のサイクリスト
あるいは スケートボーダーの走行距離と
比較し始めました
自分が１日に60kmを走ったら
「なんだこんな距離 この距離を
朝だけでやる人もいるんじゃないか」と
自分の弱さを実感しながら
否定的な螺旋に落ち込んでいきました
自分が出発する前に
抱いていたファンタジー
自分が何でもできるというファンタジーは
一体どこにあったのでしょうか？
そんな落ち込んでいたときに
改めてわかったのは
こうした大きなアドベンチャー
大きなチャレンジに挑戦するときに
それを成功させるための努力の
10％しか 肉体的な努力ではありません
その残りの90％は精神力であると
そう主張するスポーツ選手も
少なくはないと思うのですけれども
私が落ち込んでいたときに
改めてその事実に圧倒されました
この時期のメンタル的な苦労で
少しずつモチベーションが落ちていきました
これはキルギス山の
ど真ん中の場所ですけれども
ここに道があるよと言われたのです
現地の人に
地図を見せてですね
「ここを通れますか」と聞いたのです
「ああ 大丈夫です 以前も自転車で
ここを通った人もいるよ」と言われたのです
結局道はなかったんです
３日間も自転車を担いで歩きました
やっとちゃんとした道に
辿り着いたのですけれども —
この場所で出発して
3ヶ月の時点ですけれども
この場所で一番落ち込んでいました
もうギブアップに近かったです
冷静に考えたら
１週間くらいでですね
私の母国のニュージーランドに
帰ることができた訳です
ちゃんとした道に戻って バスに乗って
最寄りの空港に行って
飛行機に乗れば
すぐに楽な生活に戻れたのです
しかしまさにアドベンチャー
冒険の誘惑ですね
やめたくはなかったです
そのときに ３つの言葉に出逢いました
それは
This is it.
（英語）こんなものさ
その３つの言葉の裏には
こうしたニュアンスがあります
遠々と続く上り坂を
平らにすることはできません
何日間も吹く向かい風を
自分の力で弱めたり
止めたりすることはできません
昨日買った食料が今日の分まで足りなくて
今はお腹が空いている状況は
それはどうしようもないのです
つまり 「自分が変えることの
できないことに関しては
その状況を受け止めて
その制約の中で自分ができることに集中して
少しずつ少しずつ前に進む 」
という意味が含まれています
「This is it.」 その3つの言葉が
精神力のカギとなって
元気で進むことができました
そして最終的に
アドベンチャーと未知の世界に
引っ張られて２年半の旅となりました
そして時間が経つと
自分よりもはるかに
大きいものになってきました
ほぼ毎日更新していたブログに 世界中から
色んなフォロワーが集まってきました
そして もちろん
たくさんの人と出会うことができて
異なる人種の人々の共通の
人間性を知ることもできました
皆さんに今日 一言だけ
覚えて欲しいことがあるとしたら
それはこちらです
（英語）夢をみろ 計画せよ 実行せよ
[Dream it. Plan it. Do it.]
恥ずかしいほど決まり文句だと
言えばそうなのですけれども
無限の意味や無限の価値が
その言葉にあると思います
あなたに夢はありますか？
その夢を実現させるための
計画はありますか？
その２つの条件が揃っていれば
その計画を実行すればいいと思います
世界一周とか そういう大げさな
アドベンチャーじゃなくても
もっと身近な夢にも
この原則は働きます
転職をしたい
体を鍛えたい
あのオーケストラに入りたい
（英語）夢に見て 計画して 実行する
そして最後に ゲーテが書いたのが
要約されて名言となった言葉ですけれども
これで締めたいと思います
「あなたにできること あるいは
できると夢見ていることがあれば
すぐに始めなさい
向こう見ずは
天才であり 力であり
そして 魔法です」
ありがとうございます
（拍手）